so we picked eight actors whose lives
were completely changed by a role they
played some opened up about their
identity and sexuality others were
smashed with terrible news but turned it
into an opportunity to work on their
mental and physical health and some just
believed in their dreams so much that it
actually came true so get ready to be
inspired we know everyone discovers
themselves at a different pace but the
things that inspire people to embrace
themselves can be kind of unexpected
we're all about Will and stranger things
but who knew just how much of himself
schnapp was putting into the character
they connected on a pretty deep level
maybe that was why he said yes to his
truth Nila schnapp told the world he was
gay the Gen Z way we're talking Tick
Tock but if we're being real here the
announcement wasn't really a surprise
for the people that were closest to him
most of them literally just said we know
for real that said did the role help and
become more comfortable with the
sexuality probably living his truth on
camera meant he got to experience just
how great it could be to live as his
full self every day as for Renee rap
what well she was pretty comfortable in
her own skin early on she was lucky her
family and close friends always
supported her so she really felt allowed
to be herself but she never really
officially came out and neither did kick
Connor but anyway back to Queen Renee
this showed the sex lives of college
girls comes around she plays a queer
character in the show and knows just how
important having representation is so
she decided it was time for her to come
out to the world so she could really
advocate for her community awareness is
such a spectrum and there's so many
different like kinds of queerness and
identities of queerness this girl put in
a ton of her soul into the part and
actually helped write out the storyline
with exec producer of the show Justin
Noble and while it was all great in the
end it was still a super intense
experience she said it was like vomiting
out my deepest darkest fears about my
own internalized homophobia it made for
some very emotional days yeah no kidding
and oof okay Chris Hemsworth had it
rough for emotional days while he was
filming Limitless so this show it's a
docu-series where Chris hounds worth
goes through what he calls the six
toughest tests of his life just a lot
more difficult I thought it was going to
be but one test we don't think he was
expecting he had to do extensive genetic
tests and as it turned out he's at risk
for developing Alzheimer's he was
actually supposed to learn about the
results for the first time on camera but
the team wasn't expecting something this
big so the Show creator Darren Aronofsky
decided it would be better to break the
news to Chris before they filmed it
one-on-one instead of being scared Chris
committed to making major life changes
doing pretty much anything he could to
protect his physical and mental health
not to mention spreading the good word
with us believing that everyone should
live with as big a sense of gratitude
and love for life as you can Iman
villani she knows a thing or two about
gratitude she's the ultimate MCU nerd
AKA she's the real life Kamala Khan so
should we call this a case of Hardcore
manifesting magic maybe she's a real
life superhero because how this all
happened is kinda nuts it's crazy my
aunt was part of a group child that she
never opens one day she decided to and
there was like the Miss Marvel casting
call we seriously would have thought
this was an absolute scam but hey if it
works it works and you know it did well
not just like that she did go through a
bunch of auditions and months of
agonizing waiting but on her last day of
high school in a small town on the
outskirts of Toronto in Canada she hops
on maybe the most exciting Zoom call
that's ever existed Kevin feige and the
Marvel team letting her know that her
dream is now absolutely real added bonus
Brie Larson as a mentor but then there
are kind of nightmarish situations kit
Connor really got the short end of the
stick he was on that now canceled
Netflix series Heart Stopper fans of the
show were not happy but anyway before it
was canceled Conor was getting a ton of
hate from people saying he was taking a
queer part away from a queer actor and
all kinds of awful things about him and
let's remember he is a literal teenager
and he was still figuring himself out
the fact was he wasn't in a place where
he felt ready to be so public about his
private life but then he faced his
haters head on the people attacking him
were probably the people who should have
supported him since in the end he ended
up sharing that he was in fact bisexual
so he wasn't taking any parts away from
anyone I mean for me I just feel like
I'm perfectly you know confident and
comfortable with my sexuality even
though it all unfolded in a not so fun
way kid turned it around with the
inspiring way he
truth probably saving the lives of tons
of kids who are nervous to be themselves
or just not quite ready or sure of what
they want with all of the advocacy and
Outreach he's doing for the community
now love always wins Rebel Wilson yeah
she knows a thing or two about this as
well except she went through coming out
while being an adult which is maybe even
more intimidating she was filming a
movie called The almond and the seahorse
and then she realized she had to kiss
Charlotte gainsberg on camera she was
terrified can you can you imagine but it
didn't end up being so scary and she
actually kind of dug it realizing that
looking for a Disney prince wasn't
really all that she even said that it
kind of led to this kind of discovery
which led to my awesome partner Ramona I
might not have been open to that if I
hadn't done the emotional work no wonder
she says the movie completely changed
her life okay so are we all in agreeance
that when we think of lives completely
changing we immediately think of getting
our Hogwarts letter anyone else Dan
Radcliffe got to live that dream but did
you know Maggie Smith is the one that
actually made it all happen for real the
two of them actually met before HP on
the set of David Copperfield and then
Maggie Smith casually changes his life
by suggesting him to play Harry and
who's gonna say no to Maggie Smith the
fact was she was right Daniel is the boy
who lived and he lived his dream and
then there is Dylan O'Brien who wasn't
quite so lucky he was on set filming a
stunt for The Maze Runner sequel but
then everything went wrong we're talking
talking life flashing before your eyes
body left in a total mess he had to heal
a concussion facial fracture brain
trauma and too many other injuries to
even name it took months for him to be
physically healed and mentally well
enough so he could go back to set we
wouldn't have blamed him if he never
went back like talk about Brave here's
what he had to say about the whole thing
it took a lot of deep searching past
those gut instincts that I was having
just because of the trauma that I
experienced to realize that I did want
to finish like who new movies and TV
shows could change an actor's life so
dramatically which story was most
inspiring to you were you surprised by
how these performers dealt with any of
this stuff drop us a note in the
comments if you were feeling all the
feels that we were and let us know if
there are any inspirational after
stories that we should know about